this is historic uh we're the only
late night show to have a full
packed audience that's right
i asked our viewers to send in
photographs of themselves we turned them
into cardboard cutouts
over 15 000 people
submitted and we packed our audience
tonight here they are
270 people it's a full house
look at that crowd and andy richter's
here hey andy
hi conan how's the crowd seem oh man
these people are
pumped and they smell a lot better than
our normal audience
well that's a terrible thing to say
oh but accurate yeah but accurate yeah
we have the muskiest audience in late
night right that's what we do
that's what we advertise yes that's
that's the kind of crowd we get
uh but you know this is this is great
this i have to say
i'm getting an energy off this crowd i
know it's just
cardboard right but these are real
people
excited enough to share their
faces with us and check them out let's
take a look i'm gonna get down here and
talk to the crowd oh they love it when
you do that
look how pumped they are that i'm down
here you have such a personal touch with
people
i like the confidence of this man this
is a confident audience member yeah
he knows who he is he's happy with
himself
uh this guy also dressed up for the show
always nice to have someone from uh
paddy's irish pub
yeah yeah what an original name for an
irish pub by the way
pandering yeah pandering to you up all
night what's this
it is interesting that these are the
pictures that people thought
this is the best representation yes this
person
didn't put a lot of time in their
photograph this is as good as it gets
you know this might be his driver's
license photo
which i can't say is probably the best
idea always good to wear oh my god this
woman is beautiful
she's wearing this absolutely gorgeous
golden sorry and uh really spectacular
outfit and um very nice that uh
well i don't i'm guessing not a couple
i don't know call me crazy but i'm
saying not a couple
love love is mysterious though you never
know
here we have what appears to be a
catholic priest
and uh i hope he's asleep in this
photograph
otherwise wait let me see that guy
otherwise god my god
he's either asleep or god rest his soul
yeah yeah yeah
god rest his soul hey everybody it's
dead clergy night
on late night dead clergy night uh cat's
always a big part of the show
that seems to be uh very popular we have
a cat here
who's horrified to be sitting next to a
dead priest
and uh kovit's tough for everybody
but it's especially tough for new moms
and this woman looks like she's just
going through hell with this toddler
during covid so it was nice that we were
able
right oh boy it's tough i sympathize
yeah i sympathize it's
tough having young kids but to have
young kids during covid and then to have
to come to a taping of the show
i'm hoping it's a ventriloquist act
otherwise it's a bomber
no it's really just it's it's i just i'm
thrilled i'm absolutely thrilled that
everyone participated and we're going to
somehow figure out we're talking to the
fire marshal
we're only supposed to have 270 people
but that's real people we're gonna try
and pack
as many people in here as possible in
the nights to come so if you sent in a
picture or
still send one in because we're still
printing these out
yeah we can get thousands of people
into this theater i'm sensing we're
going to get a complaint from whoever is
behind
comey oh we have a six foot six
life-sized
uh comey yeah we started when we when we
decided to rip off the baseball
uh we started with just the cutouts we
had which was these guys
yeah we started at the very beginning
all we had
was ruth bader ginsburg the father
conrad bane from different strokes
a six foot six comey and four
count them four kevin harts
because if you buy three the fourth one
is free
they throw one in yeah yeah and so uh
yeah that's what we started out with but
i feel bad because there's someone
sitting behind comey
call me so big you know he's blocking
their view of the show can you do
anything andy
i sure can i have just the trick
oh good thing you always carry your
i love how bruce skater
vader ginsburg is hiding ah
can you see him now yes he looks like an
international
shank much much better i have been
bringing this jigsaw to work for like 15
years
i want to try something now
andy check it out tell me fishes
yeah i mean there's a there's a very
obvious joke there that i'm not gonna
say
no no one would make that joke no one
would make that joke meow
uh-oh
she you know what she doesn't look like
it but she is nuts
she goes ape [ __ ] when you come out here
i'm i you know what this is the person i
always make eye contact with when i come
out
for a real show this is the reaction
that i'm looking at and wondering
why why did you even come to the show
[Laughter]
why do you even enjoy comedy at all
yeah you look like you're here to pass a
death sentence
and you've come to a show i don't
understand yeah
she's part of a trade delegation that
i'm bringing her up with me
wow you know what sometimes
if an audience member isn't truly being
won over
you can get them by bringing them up on
stage with you does she seem any happier
now
all right it seems like she's saying no
to your loan
[Laughter]
so nice to be trying to do comedy while
my home loan is being turned down